تحيه لكم اعزائي المتابعين بانوراما من
العربيه ونناقش فيها لاول مره منذ توالي
بيض الجمهوريون يتولون زمام مجلس النواب
فهل ينفدون تهديداتهم بتعطيل قرارات
الرئيس ام ان طموحاتهم ستكون اكبر من ذلك
بعزله منصب
[موسيقى]
يتولى الجمهوريون زمام السيطره على مجلس
النواب الامريكي
لكن يتعينوا عليهم اولا التغلب على خلافات
داخل صفوفهم تتعلق بانتخابي زعيم لهم
الجدد الذين ينتخبوا خلال الاقتراع منتصف
الولايه نوفمبر الماضي لاداء القسم لمده
عامين وللمره الاولى منذ تنصيبه سيتعين
على بيض التعامل مع برلمان منقسم فقد
احتفظ حزمه الديمقراطي بالسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ لكن المعارضه الجمهوريه فازت
بغالبيه في مجلس النواب ويرى الاعضاء
الجمهوريون المنتخبون ان الامريكيين
مستعدون لبدايه تحول بعد عامين كارتييين
تحت قياده الحزب الديمقراطيه وقد وعدو
بفتح سلسله تحقيقات تتعلق باداره بايضا
للوباء والانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان
لكن قبل الشروع في ذلك يتوجه عليهم
اطلقوا على انتخاب الرئيس لمجلس النواب
وهو امر توقعه حتى الان همم تعوقه عفوا
حتى الان الانقسامات القويه في صفوف الحزب
[موسيقى]
اذا نناقش الموضوع من واشنطن مع ايهاب
عباس المحلل السياسي وامن واشنطن ايضا مع
حسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع
عن الديمقراطيات مرحبا بكما ضيفيه
الكريمين استاذ ايهاب ابدا معك اذا
الجمهوريين صحيح باغلبيه ضائله ولكن
يسيطرون على مجلس النواب كيف سيستغل
الجمهوريون هذه الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي
اهلا بحضرتك وبضيف الكريم وهو بكل
المشاهدين اين مكانه وطبعا الجمهوريون
لديهم او لديهم اا
افكار كثيره لمحاوله اعاقه اداء الرئيس
جو بايدن وادارته في عدد من الملفات التي
يعتقد الجمهوريون انها اداره غير ملائمه
لاستراتيجيات الامن القومي الامريكي ولا
استراتيجيات الولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق
بحلفائها خاصه في الاقليم الملتهبه حول
العالم نتحدث عن منطقه الشرق الاوسط نتحدث
عن مناطق همم جنوب شرق اسيا بلفات كالصين
ك- اوكرانيا الى اخره طبعا وايران طبعا
فوق كل ذلك همم المشكله اليوم ان
الجمهوريين لديهم تحدي خلال ساعات القادمه
لاختيار ماني يمثلهم ك- رئيس المجلس
النواب ال- المنافسه تدور بين همم السيد
مكارثي طبعا وهناك نائبا اخر انهما اعتقد
همم اندي بيجز واستيف سكيلز همم
هاذين وهذان الشخصان هبه طموحات ووصفها
مكارثي بانها طموحات شخصيه على حساب همم
الولايات المتحده لذلك ربما ستكون هناك
معركه صغيره داخل الحزب الجمهوري قبل ان
يتم تحديد الرئيس ومن ثم يتفرغون للملفات
المختلفه التي من خلالها همم
سيتحدون قرارات البيت الابيض وكما قال
ماكرتي قبل ذلك لن نعطي شيكا على بيض مثلا
اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق بحربها ضد روسيا مثل
الحسين عبد الحسين ما رايك الى اين سيصل
الجمهوريون في صراعهم مع همم
الديمقراطيه هل سيجعلون فقط حياته صعبه
سيفتح من تحقيقات سيعطلون مشاريع القوانين
التي يريد ان يمررها سيعطلون مساله ربما
الدعم لاوكرانيا فقط ويفتح هنا تحقيق ايضا
في مساله نجله ام سيذهبون بعيدا ربما
سيعذلون
مساء الخير طبعا اوافق الاستاذ ايهاب
بالقول انه اييي قدره الجمهوريين هي
التعطيل وبالاهره هي تنحصر بالتعطيل لانه
انت لديك غرفه واحده من سلطه من بين ثلاثه
لديه الرئاسه الديمقراطيون لديهم الرئاسه
ولديه الشيوخ هذا يعني انه مثلا
الاطاحه او محاوله خلع بيضه متعذره تماما
لانها تحتاج الى غرفتي
ولكن اعتقد انه الحقل الوحيد المجال
الوحيد الذي سيتمكن همم فيه الجمهوريون من
عرقله عمل بيضين الى حد كبير هو موضوع
الموازنه السنويه التي يتم اقراها وهناك
موضوع اخر يتعلق برفع سقف الاستدانه
العامه للولايات المتحده ولكن عدى عن ذلك
كل المواضيع الاخرى اعتقد انه ما يزال لدى
القدره كامله خصوصا في السياسه الخارجيه
وعادها يعني يمكنه الحكم بمراسيم شراعيه
وخاصه انه مجلس الشيوخ ايضا يعني الى
جانبه فهو يمكنه فرض فيتو لكن لن يحتاج
الى فيتو لونه اصلا مش شيوخ تسيطر عليه
غالبيه نعم استاذ ايهاب عباس ما رايك هل
فعلا الجمهوريون ليس لديهم الكثير ليفعلوه
كي ينقصوا حياه بيضا
لا هو تنظيف الحياه سيتم سيتم همم بكل
تاكيد لكن همم فكره همم بعد ذلك الامور
تذهب عاده الى مجلس الشيوخ للتصويت عليها
ومن ثم اقراها همم اتفق طبعا مع الاستاذ
حسين في هذا الاطار همم لان في نهايه
المطاف مجلس الشيوخ ياخذ القرارات الهامه
مثلا من الممكن لمجلس النواب ان يحرك همم
الاتهامات ضد بايدينا او ضد حتى هانترب
لكن نتحدث عن بايرن انا ممكن ان يحركها
وتذهب همم كره الثلج الكبيره الى مجلس
الشيوخ الذي سيحتاج عند اذن الى ثلثي
الاعضاء التصويت على ادانت الرئيس مثلا
ومن ثم سيفشل هذا الامر بسبب سيطره
الديمقراطين همم بالضبط نفس الفكره التي
حدثت مع الرئيس السابق همم دونالد ترامب
ومحاوله محاكمته عندما كان الجمهوريه
يسيطرون على مجلس الشيوخ لم يحدث اي شيء
طبعا الرئيس السابق في هذا الايجار لكن من
الممكن ان تحدث منورات سياسيه عده ممكن ان
يقدم الجمهوريين مطالبات للرئيس بايدن
كنوع من انواع المبادله السياسيه للتنازل
عن هذا التعطيل من الممكن ان تعطينا همم
موافقات في هذا الامر او بدلا من الموافقه
على ميزانيه ضخمه لمساعده اوكرانيا بعشرات
المليارات فلنجعلها بمليارين او ثلاثه
ويحدث ببيت او مجادله كبيره في هذا بطبع
من الممكن ان يحدث لكن مجلس النواب عاده
يهتم دائما
بالفكره الميزانيه كما قال الصديق العزيز
من واشنطن ويستطيع دائما ان يتحدى الاداره
الامريكيه في هذا الامر بل هو من الممكن
ان يعوقها بشكل كبير جدا نعم طيب استاذ
حسين عبد الحسين العلاقه الان بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين في المشهد
السياسي الامريكي يعني الديمقرا من 21 الى
الان الى 2023 اذا على مجلس النواب وكما
ذكر الاستاذ ايهاب الانقلبت همم الايه
الديمقراطيون في مجلس الشيوخ والجمهوريون
في النواب هل كيف يمكن توصيف هذه المرحله
في الكونغرس الامريكي هل همم يمكن القول
انه العلاقه صحيحه سياسيه في في صالح يعني
الحركه السياسيه ام لا نحن نشهد استقطابا
وين ينبا بصراع حاد ربما في المرحله
المقبله
لا لا ارى انه الوضع الصحي سياسيين همم
والاستقطاب ليس بين الحزبين فقط الاستطاب
داخل الحزب الواحد نحن نتكلم الان حتى
الان لم ينجح همم السيد كامل مكارثي في
الحصول على الاصوات المطلوبه داخل حزبه
يعني هو غير قادر على اداره الغالبيه ما
بالك انه يقوم باصدار قوانين اعتقد انه
الامر الوحيد الذي يجمع عليه جمهوريون هو
العداء للديمقراطيين وهذا الامر نفسه
الديمقراطيين عندما يكون يعني لو طرحنا
مثلا قصه
او اي قصه اخرى مثلا تتعلق ترى ان هناك
يعني شبه وحده لدى الحزم لانه العدو مشترك
ولكن عندما يعني يتعدى الموضوع انه
الاعداء او الخصومه للفريق الاخر وتصبح
الامور المتعذره طبعا انت بعد همم تفاصيل
الانتقام المكان في ترى ان هناك يعني
احزاب داخل الحزب الجمهوري رافضه طبعا
وهناك منافسه كبيره بين يعني بين جمهوريين
انفسهم بين الجمهوريه صحيح هو هناك اختلاف
في الراي من بين الاختلافات الموجوده داخل
الحزب الجمهوري هي طريقه التعاطي مع
اوكرانيا وطريقه الدعم لاوكرانيا مثلا كل
ماكارتي كان قال همم خلال همم انتخابات
منتصف الولايه قال ان حزبه لا يقدم شيكا
على بياض كما ذكرته استاذ ايهاب
فيما يعاني الامريكيون من همم الركود ماذا
نتوقع همم اذا طبعا همم صعد ماكارفي الى
رئاسه مجلس النواب همم كيف سيكون همم اثر
هذا الصعود على المساعدات الولايات
المتحده كانت تعاهدت بمنح 100 مليار دولار
من المساعدات العسكريه والانسانيه
لاوكرانيا
صحيح بيقولوا تاكيد يعني اليوم هناك
معاناه عسكريه امريكيه بشكل او باخر فيما
يتعلق بالمخزون العسكري الامريكي الذي
يبدو انه تاثر كثيرا بالعمليات العسكريه
في اوكرانيا بسبب تقديم هذا الدعم الى
متناهي نعلم ذلك بان اقول ذلك لماذا لانه
هناك اخبار شاهدناها خلال الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه ان واشنطن مثلا قامت
باعاده شراء اسلحه بعتها لكوريا الجنوبيه
لتعيد مره اخرى ارسالها الى الى اوكرانيا
قامت بارسال قنابل صغيره على محركات
صواريخ صغيره الى اوكرانيا بعد ان تم
تعديلها وتركيبها بصوره تصلح ان تكون همم
فاعل اكثر في هذه الحرب ف- اا بالاضافه
الى ان همم رئيس الاركان الامريكي همم
السيد مارت ميلي قال ان همم على واشنطن ان
تبدا في محاولات ايجاد همم
منافذ دبلوماسيه لانهاء هذا الحوار
العسكري بين اوكرانيا وهمم روسيا هناك من
الممكن تكون همم معانا عسكريه في تقديم
الدعم لا متناهيه الذي تسعى اليه دائما
اداره جو بايرن وبالتالي هذه النقطه ستكون
حاسمه للجمهوريين للتاكيد عليها كما نقول
دائما اا يعني هناك ما يسمى بالهضباطن
الزر الساخن كلما تضغط عليه لدى المواطن
الامريكي كلما استفزيت تستفز المواطن
الامريكي وتجعله يذهب بصوته الى الطرف
الاخر هذا ماذا يفعله الجمهوريون سيؤكد له
المواطن الامريكي اكثر ان ديمقراطيين
يصرفون اكثر من اللازم في مجال دعم
اوكرانيا ولا يهتمون بجيب المواطن
الامريكي الذي ترى كثيرا خلال الفتره
الماضيه بسبب الاثار العكسيه للعقوبات
التي فرضت من الولايات المتحده والقوه
الغربيه على روسيا الى التضخم نعم نعم
استاذ حسين ما قاله استاذ ايهاب كثير مهم
يعني انه في مرحله الركود الاقتصادي وهناك
الصندوق النقد الدولي لان يتوقع طبعا همم
ركودا اقتصاديا في سنه 2023 وارتفاع تكلفه
المعيشه من السهل جدا اقناع الامريكي بان
الاداره الدي استطيع الحاليه هي اداره
سيئه في مساله همم تحسين حياه الامريكيين
صحيح الجمهوريون لن يكن لديهم اليد الطولا
لتعطيل قرارات بايظين بشكل مباشر وحاسم
ولكن هذا لن يؤثر على مستقبل ربما اذا ما
اراد جو بيدن اعاده انتخابه او اعاده
ترشحه مره ثانيه لولايه ثانيه انني يؤثر
على حظوظ الديمقراطيين في الفوز
بالانتخابات المقبله كذلك
يعني ولكن نحن ما زال هناك همم لدينا
سنتين حتى نصل لموعد الانتخاب
وغالبا ما يكون الاقتصاد بشكل عام يعني لا
تصريحات الجمهوريين او الديمقراطيين
واحدهم يعني مثلا الفصل الذي سيجري فيه
الانتخاب في خريف من عام 2024 ان كان
الاقتصاد الامريكي في وضع جيد النمو
وهناك وظائف يكون وضع ايضا بغض النظر اما
يقوله الجمهوريون والعكس يعني هكذا يحصل
ايضا عندما يكون مرشح من الجمهوريين ولكن
انا اسمح لي ان اشير انه المعركه حول
اوكرانيا هي ليست حول اوكرانيا فحسب وانما
هي جزء من التجاذب بين الطرفين لانه
اوكرانيا لا يتم التصويت عليها يعني همم
باب وحيد وانما كجزء من موازنه كبرى ولذلك
تدخل في باب المفاوضات الشد والجذب يعني
يقول الجمهوريون نعطيكم اوكرانيا
اعطيتمونا في مكان اخر يعني لكل حزب لديه
حسابات
فاعتقد انه هذا الموضوع الاكبر الذي
العرقله الاكبر التي سيعاني منها بايضا
وطبعا الموازنه يعني هي ال- الجزء الاصغر
من المشكله الجزء هو الدين العام بانه هذا
ياتي بتصويت منفصل عن الموازنه
واعتقد انه يعني سيعاني كثيرا كما انا
اوباما لانه سيحاول الجمهوريون فرض سقف
همم لمنع الاستدانه واعت هذا طبعا هذا
الموضوع يؤثر في مصداقيه الولايات المتحده
وقدره الحكومه على الاستدانه في الاسواق
الماليه نعم طيب استاذ ايهاب عباس نقطه
اخرى تبدو مهمه كذلك العلاقه مع الصين همم
وطبعا تقليل الاعتماد على الصين بالنسبه
لامريكا هناك يعني مقاربه جمهوريه واضحه
في هذا الاطار سيطرت الجمهوريين على مجلس
النواب ما الذي يمكن ان يتوقع من خلالها
لجهه علاقه امريكا
وتسيرها لملف علاقاتها مع الصين
يعني في هذا الملف تحديدا دعني اذاكر فقط
بما قام به الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
عندما قام بتوقيع اتفاق تجاري ضخم مع
الصين في بدايات اعتقد عام 2000 او في
اواخر عام 2019 على ما اعتقد او في بدايات
ام عام 2020 وكان هذا بعد طبعا حرب تجاريه
طاحنه وفرض رسوم جمركيه متبادله ومشاكل
اقتصاديه كبيره بين الاقتصاديه بين الاكبر
المشكله في العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه ان
الميزان التجاري مختلفه الصين وان الصين
تدين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعقود
خزانه تقدر قيمتها بما يزيد عن تريليون
و400 مليار دولار هذا سيكون وتاثير سلبي
كبير جدا في العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
خلال الفتره القادمه خاصه مع التحرشات
السياسيه انجاز التعبير استخدام ذلك من
قبل بعض السياسيين كما شاهدنا في اداره جو
فايدن والحزب الديمقراطي عامه لا اقول
الاداره ولكن لا نقول الحزب الديمقراطي
فكره ذهاب نانسي بيلوسي لزياره تايوان
وبعد ذلك وفد من الكونجرس بالاضافه
للمواقف المختلفه التي تتخذها اداره جو
بادن في هذا الملف الملف الصينيون فسيكون
هناك صراع كبير بين الجانبين اعتقد ستحد
من قوه هذا الصراع الاداء او الاداءات
الجمهوريه لان الجمهوريين يعتقدون في
الصين صحيح هي منافس تجاري لكن يعتقدون
انها همم من الممكن ان تكون ايضا صديق
تجاري عكس الديمقراطيه يعتقدون ان القطر
ياتي من الصين في هذا الاطار طيب استاذ
حسين عبد الحسين سؤال اخر يبدو مهما كذلك
هي مساله اذا ما قرر الجمهوريون الذهب
بعيدا في صراعهم مع بايدن وارادوا الذهاب
باتجاهله هل يستطيعون حقا من خلال
الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب هل يستطيعون ان
يعزلوا بان
همم يستطيعون لانه براي يمكنهم الحصول على
غالبيه هذا موضوع لا مبارك عليه بين
الجمهوريين على عكس يعني مثلا انتخاب رئيس
للكونجرس كما نرى اليوم الانقسام اليوم
هذا الموضوع
من انتخاب رئيس المجلس النواب لهذه الدرجه
الصراع بين الجمهوريين كبير
الى حد ما الحصول على اصوات ال 222 نائب
في الكونجرس الجمهوريين يعني في الكونجرس
هو موضوع عليه اجماع ولكن لم يذهب ابدا من
ذلك يعني تصوت على خلع الرئيس ولكن يتوقف
الموضوع في يعني في هذا في مجلس النواب ان
ذهب الى ميسي شيوخ لا يحصل شيء لا يوجد
لديهم اصلا غالبيه الثلثين ولا يوجد لديهم
اصلا غالبيه البسيطه حتى
فالموضوع قد يعني انت قام الجمهوريون
بخطوه من هذا النهار تكون خطوه لارضاء
المحاسبين ولكن لا يوجد يعني افق لديها
اعتقد انهم قد يذهبون الى اللجان في
محاوله يعني اثاره
الضجيج حول موضوع او علاقات هانتربوينت
ربما بالصين اوكرانيا ولكن هذا يكون ضجيج
فقط سياسي تجتمع اللجان تاخذ قرارات مثلا
تطلب حضور
هنتر ايضا شخصيا مثله امام همم لجنه
لشهاده ما كل هذا من من باب المسرح
السياسي ولكن ان لا اعتقد ان هناك قدره
كافيه للجمهوريين همم او الغالبيه
الجمهوريه قدره كافيه لايذاء بايضا بشكل
غير سياسي يعني لدفع مثلا من خلال وزاره
العدل او القيام باجراءات عادل كالتي حاول
القيام بها
نعملها اعتقد في هذه المساله هل تعتقد
فعلا انه لن يستطيعوا يعني نساء سينغسون
حياه بايضا هذا اكيد ولكن لن يصلوا في
النهايه الى عزله اا اتفق طبعا اتفق تماما
كنت اريد فقط ان اثير نقطه اخرى تدور في
نفس الاطار وهي همم محاوله ادانت الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب واللجنه البرلمانيه
من مجلس النواب التي تعمل منذ عمل 2018 في
هذا الاطار هذه اللجنه التي قدمت توصيات
لوزاره العدل بتوجيهتهم مختلفه الى الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب طبعا واا امور اخرى
متعلقه هذه اللجنه خلال ربما ساعات او
ايام قليله جدا سيتم حلها وكل هذا سيذهب
ابراج الري
اح شكرا جزيلا لكم مضيفيه الكريمين ايهاب
عباس محلل السياسي من واشنطن ومن واشنطن
ايضا وحسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه
الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات مشاهدينا شكرا لكم
انتم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء